l'infa blâme c'est un laboratoire de
fabrication numérique c'est un le type
de projet qui a démarré il ya une
dizaine d'années om haïti l'idée c'est
de déposer les outils de fabrication
numérique entre les mains des
utilisateurs et donc de les mettre dans
la situation où ils peuvent
effectivement fabriquer leurs objets
eux-mêmes dans un fab lab en principe
notre fab lab est dédiée à la production
d'objets pour l'interaction de machines
et pour la visualisation de données
donc on est plutôt dans le champ des
compute insight
le réseau des fab lab qui se constituent
sur le plateau de saclay il ya encore
assez informelle mais on sait qu'il ya
un certain nombre d'initiatives qui sont
en cours parce que je participe à un
groupe de travail
porté par la fcs donc la fondation du
campus paris saclay donc il ya un
certain nombre d'initiatives qui sont à
la fois au niveau de l'université de
saint quentin en yvelines d'une école
qui s'appelle l'estac a ensuite
évidemment pour les ceux qui existent
déjà il ya le 503 qui fait partie de
l'institut d'optique
on a ensuite le nsk chant l'iut hoeness
de cachan qui effectivement a déjà des
pratiques de ce type là aussi on a aux
ulis aussi à un fab labs mobile qui a
été mis en place
il y à d'autres initiatives d'ailleurs
un tas de collaboration sont en train de
se faire cependant tous les fab lab en
question pour l'instant ne sont pas
ouverts à tous les publics donc ils ne
remplissent pas complètement leur
t-shirt de fab lab
les forces de ce réseau de fab lab ou
10,9 lab
si on peut utiliser un autre terme pour
décrire des fab lab qui sont pas encore
tout à fait des semblables c'est c'est
cette dimension territoriale et
programmatique
c'est à dire qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'installations qui sont en train d'être
construite il ya un maillage il ya un
réseau qui va permettre à des gens
notamment moi et d'autres fablab de
partager des publics
ça ça va être vraiment très très
intéressant et en termes d'innovation à
la fois technologique et sociétale ce
sera une belle expérience à suivre